all right joining me now is Tulsi
gabbard former Hawaii congresswoman and
Fox News contributor Tulsi good to have
you in studio thank you look at these
pictures now we're showing you these are
side-by-side pictures you have Eagle
Pass Texas where we only have one person
there I don't know why we're showing
that photo but the other but we got
Eagle Pass Texas uh showing you know
people streaming across the border
they're just climbing over the Border
fence and walking across and we also
have a situation in oh that's Delaware
okay that's not a border uh where
Biden's about to land for a weekend of
well
who knows what so you know a border of
insanity on the left and uh the other
border on the right but the guy's
ignoring the Border yeah it's um you
know you hit it right on the head it is
very clear that this President and his
administration they don't care about
securing this country they don't care
about the interests and well-being of
the American people who are being
impacted very negatively impacted by the
Biden Harris Administration open border
policy so you have people who not only
live in the southern border states now
as you're seeing there in that footage
of New York people all across the
country are being impacted by these
unprecedented levels of illegal
immigrants crossing the border and it's
the cartels and the human traffickers
are the ones who are benefiting and
profiting now the Eagle Pass scenes
we're looking at right now Tulsi or live
pictures you and I during the time we
were sitting here before the show
started saw dozens and dozens just
hopping across they just walk across the
razor wire kind of hop across it then
they just say hi to the Border Patrol
officials and then they're processed and
then they essentially in a matter of you
know a couple of hours usually because
they don't have anywhere to keep these
people they're released
policy Tulsi with a notice to appear
piece of paper they can get on a plane
they can travel on any mass
transportation they usually get a you
know a plane ticket or a bus ticket to
wherever they want to go right and most
people like wait a second I haven't even
traveled in the last year because I
can't afford it yeah it's it is an open
door open border policy and what we're
seeing is uh you know no matter how many
times mayorkas or anyone from the Biden
Administration or democrat Elites in
Congress they say oh the border border
policies are working the border is
secure everybody coming across the
border knows that it's not and that they
can get away with this we got to go back
to the Trump policy of remain in Mexico
we got to go back to the policy of
actually securing our borders whether
through physical or electronic means and
Congress and the administration have to
work together to fix these broken Asylum
laws now they've got the new stats that
just came in from Tucson they're they're
just reeling at Tucson and they're
getting no help 13
000 apprehensions 1300 rescues 23 human
smuggling events nine narcotics events
one firearm sees that is just the tip of
the iceberg I mean that's just Tucson
yeah don't put that you think there's
only one firearm involved in bringing in
13 000 people across our border Tulsi um
yeah
mayor Karen bass who is out there making
a comment in axio saying we live in a
city that welcomes immigrants and so I
think you know we I guess we have the
sound bite we'll show it
we live in a city that welcomes
immigrants and so I think we have been
able to handle it but I am fearful that
any day planes could start coming
well that's I mean no because they all
should stay in Texas well of course yeah
exactly they they they're not getting
obviously the the real threat uh that is
occurring right before our eyes because
they should all be sent to La San
Francisco Chicago New York Washington DC
well the people in Washington they go
home for the weekend so they don't care
but all the big liberal cities they have
to feel the effect of their own policies
right but in all these big liberal
cities we see many many homeless people
oh many people who are struggling just
to be able to get by their social
welfare systems are already being
stressed they don't have enough money so
do you agree that the Democrats might
try to pull some little stuff some
little sister Soldier moment with the
border and try to like with show like 10
deportations and like put that on a
viral loop it's something we should
definitely keep an eye out for I would
be surprised if they didn't think that
voters are so stupid that if they try to
put shiny wrapping on this horrible
horrible problem that we're somehow
gonna buy it before uh this next
election but this is a carrier I think
is is Big don't you agree but if he's a
very well respected the thing that I saw
in there though is he admitted this is
politically driven it's not driven out
of a concern for the country or the
people they want to remake the country
do they not in part they want cheap
labor they also want a kind of new
electorate yeah I mean it's fairly yeah
exactly tell us great to see you thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else